anyway there's this tick-tocker
who says she doesn't want anyone who
voted for trump to do a number of
services for her like ringing up her
groceries fixing her car providing
others so grown well i don't know how
this oldest woman is
50 over 50 i would say that's my guess
don't hate if i got it wrong but let's
just take a listen to what she says and
you tell me if this sounds like a grown
adult
let's see i don't know if i'm being a
bit extreme with this but
prior to 2016
i go in the supermarket and there's a
person next to me
the clerk who checked me now go to the
doctor's office talk to the receptionist
the doctor go to the dentist
get my car fixed
i had no issue
now
now
2022
i'm looking at the receptionist at the
doctor's office and wondering if she's a
trump supporter
i'm wondering if my mechanic
voted for trump
i don't want you fixing my [ __ ]
car right
at the supermarket the cashier who's
ringing me through
did you vote for trump
because i don't want you ringing my [ __ ]
up
my dentist don't be drilling me [ __ ] if
you voted for trump
is anybody else like me
there are people like that i mean you
know this is not a joke there are people
that exist like like this this and joy
behar like that is joy could make that
video and mean it i'm not playing
i remember her telling a story on the
view about
masks and something she wouldn't go she
wouldn't go into the dentist's office
unless everybody had gotten the vaccine
they all had to tell her it's none of
your business girlfriend what they did
and didn't do
i can't with these people these statists
this big government like these little
tyrants many tyrants anyway here's
another little tyrant
i hope that listen i don't want your car
to stall on the side of the road lady
but it happens to all of us right and
you know what you do in those moments
you call triple a you call you call
somebody unless you're from texas in
which case you probably hop out of the
car and you change that tire yourself am
i right tyler
yes okay
self-sufficiency is a beautiful thing
see you come from one of the red states
you're like i'm not i don't need to call
i get out get your you ever see those
people on the side of the road i just
observe in awe coming from new york
i i learned how to change time i don't
do it well i haven't had enough practice
but anyway you call most people go to
the side of the road women in particular
and we're like somebody help me
help me do you know i hope that she
calls aaa and they come and she says did
you vote for trump and they say yeah
and i hope she says well i don't want
you to change my tire and they're like
peace out see you later
bye
how dumb is this
how unbelievably narrow-minded and
nauseating is it that everybody that
exists in your orbit at every second of
every day has to agree with your
politics
can you imagine that these people are
trying to exist in an adult world
where do they live
where their own maybe new york city who
knows everybody there is like a stafford
wive just completely hypnotized
maybe that's where
most people are not this way though
right most people are just like whatever
who cares as long as you're not shoving
your thoughts down my face 24 hours a
day what do i care if i go to the
dentist and somebody feels differently
this is a sickness
this is a sickness that has emerged
among adults
adult babies won
and this is not a mentally healthy
person
now she laughs at the end maybe it's all
a big joke i don't know but i can tell
you there are people that say this with
a straight face i know them in new york
city some used to be friends
they got a little upset with me about
the mandates you know i was endangering
other people
i wasn't they all got covered after that
ridiculous and how far does this go does
she call and vet her plumber like are
you not gonna have your plumber come fix
your pipes if if he voted for trump are
you not gonna buy goods from walmart
because the truck driver possibly voted
for trump are you gonna call walmart
there are people like this in new york
city who ask
i'm not kidding i believe they ask about
your politics and if they don't get a
response they like they're like no now i
think it would be interesting i think
the timing is is key though right like
if she's
someone's bagging your groceries she's
not going to want to do that and then
they're like they i oh it would be great
it would be great if people just started
vomiting out i voted for trump
anyone not want your groceries backed
here and people are just like wait she
would let her let me tell you something
in a tight spot push comes to show she's
not gonna be like oh you voted for trump
never mind i'll back my own no you're
gonna just you're gonna let that one
slide and then go home and be like i'll
just leave that part out of the video
got my groceries her toilet's backing up
it's like coming out of the shower drain
did you vote for trump you know who does
it the privileged right the privileged
the elitists in new york that they can
afford to just oh you really
i can't i just can't do it honestly this
is a big beautiful world there's a lot
of people in it that feel differently
about things if you can't co-exist with
them honestly stick a pacifier in your
mouth put on a diaper and if you're
gonna act like a baby start dressing
like one if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]